Now let's take a look at one of the hardest
things to deal with, with working with the app cache. The
fact that you have to remember to update the application
cache. Let's say, we change something in our file, let's add
a title. Now, let's save this and go back and
try to reload again. Now, you'll notice that even though I
saved the index.html file Nothing happened to the cashe. It's
because the only thing that was checked was the cashe file,
the manifest, and we didn't touch the manifest at all. So let's go back and do
that now. So in the manifest, we need to do some actual change to the file. We
can't just touch it with the command line
utility touch. That actually won't trigger a reload.
So let's just add a version number hit
save and now let's go back and reload again.
This time you'll see again we've downloaded the
cache. But remember what we are seeing here, what
the user is seeing here is not actually the
new content. It loaded it from the cache. And
then updated the cache, not in real time, that
way the user gets the content immediately, while they
still get updated content. Now we can listen for
the event on cache updated, and the cache update
event will tell us that the user really needs to
pick a good time to reload. We could surface that by
popping a dialog box that says, Hey, this application is
updated. Do you want to reload now? But, that can also be
postponed, and you can just presume that the user will
get a new version, when they hit refresh again. If I
hit refresh one more time, now it's pulling it from
the cache again, and I have the updated content over here.